2787 that's a difference of 200 more
than 200 points and a confident hold
there by Karthik he's got reasons to be
proud the pawns have been traded off and
we're just single pawns remaining he
gives a check he's going to pick up the
G4 Pawn a car is going to pick up the G6
pawn it will be handshakes Hikaru
Nakamura is not going to be happy with
this result
yeah but actually nobody can blame him
because he played a good game simply
that he's open and played fantastically
I mean what are the zeusfulness what an
incredible defense there
uh well this is the World Cup this is
the World Cup and we see two bear Kings
and a handshake
it is the World Cup where we see
surprising matchups and big upsets and
Karthik venkatarama who was excited who
was looking forward to play World number
two Hikaru Nakamura with the black
pieces gets the draw in the first game